oh my god today is a big day you saw the
video I did recently where I said I
waited four years to play this The Last
Guardian is finally out so many didn't
think it was actually going to happen I
think it almost got canceled for a long
time but defense are such hardcore fans
of this this type of game sends shadow
Colossus that they brought it out and
just please if you're watching this and
at any point feel like you're excited
about checking this game ah don't
hesitate support support games like this
I imagine it's harder for games that try
and be more artsy and creative to really
be more commercial rather than do that
last Call of Duty or the last Final
Fantasy which I'm sure are great games
but it would be cool to see more of this
and I would I would love if my video can
help support support games like this
PlayStation sent one of these awesome
thing just so I can brag a little bit so
it has to fete Jesus so it has the
feathers right but when you open it
watch this
Last Guardian it's like a little 3d
thing okay
very cool the game and a lull feather
and I think it says this is copy 123 out
of 2000 and 456
there's only 2500 of these which is not
I guess not that only but I wouldn't be
surprised if this sold for a lot on eBay
let's just say that so I really
appreciate that PlayStation send me one
of these now [ __ ] that okay let's just
get into the game whoa this is gonna be
an epic epic series please do leave a
like to support the first episode it
really means a lot and let's get into
this gonna be a daily Staley show I why
not just get started right away and it
just get started right away what is this
what am I looking at I didn't give it a
much thought it's a it's a ground that's
the sentence it's a ground it's a floor
it's a kids I'm getting not getting a
sense of scale here what are we okay
what is happening that's our hero
beautiful The Last Guardian in case you
can't read what does that mean them for
me to wear that probably butcher that
name
in a world where beasts oh and my god
bees it's very cool so far got cool
birds and [ __ ] got bats with little feet
that's cute and a bellybutton and dogs
with beard that's cool
and we got cat dogs
and goat goats Bank goats are so creepy
look at them that looks like a pillow
that's it that's a unicorn in a world
where mystical beast lives
that's a Griffon isn't it Griffis look
at that
that's cool got gloves and [ __ ] got a
Phoenix it is and then we have Treecko
so that's its name maybe Treecko the
rarest of them all design and directed
by for me to win it
cool so I remember this when I died I
had to like you have to click to get
those away it took me a long time to
figure out when it first happened I'm
like what the [ __ ] is this but am i
moving the chains no I'm not all right
there's Treecko he looks hurt remember a
bro from shadow Colossus the horse in
Omo - OH - no I saw a bear
hakuna oh we see here the Poonam
[Music]
flying through the darkness and now we
move we wake up so we are already old
and we're telling the story from our
childhood
[Music]
all right let's wake up oh those are my
cocoon ugh we're Tanya very interesting
way of storytelling and there's tricky
[Music]
and we seemed pretty shocked by Trika
what all right let's go up again inuzuka
beauty so I don't I get talked to other
children boys totally cool
he's a man-eating beast owner owner not
to Ali's and the tattoos I guess Iranian
doors
he knows are the otaku are you Muslim
annoy me I mean I must be pretty drunk
if you wake up without many tattoos you
know well at least didn't wake up with a
tribal you know Treecko oh my god what
happened okay movie Jews are they kiss
or do no money no thanks so we woke up
here and we don't know what happened
I think trigger trust us yet
because we're sneaking no we're not can
I help you Trika let me look that looks
painful let me pull that out help you
with it easy boy easy easy easy trick oh
I'm try
I'm not trying to trick oh you sorry I'm
sorry okay I'm on remove the spear this
is like reverse head of a colossal there
it is oh geez ow ah [ __ ]
well that won't do it no we didn't die
did we thanks Treecko
okay waking up again we're not feeling
too well but I hope Treecko is Jesus
Christ what a bad hangover for this
little dude
now still not too oh you can walk now
nevermind sign ohto - are you toasty the
gig Oh Tori cool hunger in for something
oh there we go up there there's one of
these
I remember you feed them to them see so
you jump with this fun okay now how do I
pull myself up okay I pick up the barrel
you hungry buddy ow
that's cool I love the animation so cool
so pretty look at alright now we're
gonna throw at you
cuz he was nailed it nailed it Rico good
job
I'm trying to help you here you know
what you wanted me to spoon feed you
okay sorry sorry you wanted or not I'll
get to Tori cool Oh another camp easy to
you just trust me other do Arya Tosti
the king
you know you toss the earth to Z dude
that's like a lot of them what if we got
here then it's interesting how the the
storytelling is helping how to progress
I really like that
alright well dude I got like how much do
you need buddy like I'm feeling like
okay what is this drugs this is like
catnip or some [ __ ] here you go
you're a [ __ ] welcome by the way you
want more fine huh nailed it I love how
you toss love it's awesome I'm still
kind of learning the controls it's a bit
weird alright where is he Oh you ate one
okay you're feeling better now that you
got your butterfly juice buddy you want
some all right
there you go your [ __ ] shut up
eat it that's it come out maybe he only
if he can't see me
is he gonna uh he does haha he's just
like Edgar oh oh it's gonna eat another
one it really is amazing how they did
their little beast cuz it really feels
like I'll oh it feels dumb just like my
own pet you know cuz you know I'm here
are you happy now do you trust me
does he sneeze if we approach him hey
rude
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
I'm down buddy fine you know what I
don't want to be here anyway - Tori Kuno
another gem either do odd are two other
do Aria Tosti to kick in Aras you tossed
a r2z oughta do here he hit our hostel
Adam ultra-clean wants to eat more but
there's food more there you're stupid
alright doesn't see us now just eat okay
here we go
stupid Treecko
ma ma there you go you're happy now
surprise it was me all along I am the
hand that fed you you should be happy
thanks for kicking come on dude
come on Treecko you got a trick up she's
still oh no see okay a guy you're lookin
like - I'll go - Cara go 60 Adam I guess
for the most junior - good I'll help you
with this chain oh it's so cute hey
buddy don't I can't come near it now so
I think I'm gonna have to go up here
take it easy buddy
do not kick me get a holiday
Odysseys in a kadhai dude oh there's a
spear Nate's right shoulder Ino YZ o
Krishna Z ultra Clarence en
here we go oh the spear alright this is
gonna sting a little bit you're not
kicking me again [ __ ] huh why do you
keep doing that really oh man
[Music]
great
you
what a great start we really truly did
it
we took three naps on now you're now
you're happy now you like me
you
[Music]
okay all right morning breath thank you
don't you smell very nice all right we
need to get you off this chain dude I
can call him now Yatta to ya do oh he's
up and running huh okay so how why would
I call him how he follows but he can't
go too far is there anywhere I would
like him to go I don't know let's try
and get this chain away all right let's
pull up on it all right Rico I'm not
trying to tickle your ass I'm just
trying to set you free all right here we
go hold a lover
how convenient ah there that's better
isn't it
ow why don't I not grip him
where am I here we go all right
beautiful me this is so cool oh he's
shaking off the armor you're free
Treecko you look a little naked but
that's okay I'm not gonna let go working
a guy so now we can direct him where to
go which honestly I don't know where how
about up there how about up there where
we came from for my care oh this way oh
cool
I didn't know we could go here come on
trick oh come on bye cruel man it's so
pretty oh my god look at this incredible
hey buddy hey look who came huh mr. fish
feet all right I'm gonna have to climb
trigger to get up here
there we go are you stand still there's
gonna be a lot I do do not fart right
now man okay just stay right okay you
made the [ __ ] all right
that's not what I wanted to do and I'm
kind of terrified there we go that's
what I totally what I wanted to do you
want some more juice all right you want
some of this you know I have to eat too
you know oh I'm sorry
and I think I can go in here oh I can
cool
whoa what the hell okay this is
unexpected but we're doing it we're
going through keep crawling
hopefully there's no snakes I'm super
scared of snakes if trigger was a snake
I don't know how much I would like this
game you know what I mean if he's a bird
bird dog cat thing then yeah you know
it's cool all right hey whoa cool that
light where oh Jesus I sort of
accidentally went in here what is this
odds all right
okay let's check this out whoa it's like
it's like a Gyptian pickup thing I'll be
taking this
whoa whoa whoa what the hell
illuminate hold down and move Latin
anyhoo love oh my god cool second point
is to arcing you know to go yeah huddle
see who's dis yo see you're no no - I
decided to borrow and smoked great all
right whatever you however you want to
tell the story
oh cool I can equip it alright let's go
back and shine it somewhere where the
Sun don't shine this is so cool I'm
blown away by this game so far okay
where did we come from
listen here yeah yeah yeah definitely if
I can just manage to get into that
suspicious-looking hole there we go how
we had to under quit man okay now I'm
not questioning the logic of that being
a part of my sweater but it's hovering
okay it's hot so it's hovering have you
ever heard about that so bright isn't it
face is [ __ ] blowing up
oh you had a good nap oh it lets up what
the hell
hmm oh oh he doesn't like it
oh yeah he gets scared of like ancient
tech dude your eyes are like [ __ ]
holographs Jesus Christ went fine dude
what kind of [ __ ] are you smoking okay
let's be careful using that right now
but let's find where then the firt the
third person this feels a little bit
like Mario 64 like it's a lot of times
where you don't want it to be and I wish
I could go in the first-person mode a
little bit cuz this is kind of weird
okay let's go down okay what if we use
it whoa whoa whoa what the hell is
happening a tunic a macaque also boy Oh
Tariq Oh No Oh easy oh yeah is it eat a
lot too you can shoot [ __ ] lightning
you read oh boy
Oh Tariq uno yeah war oh hell is this
that's a surprise
okay well he's done here so I guess we
are as well if we can shoot freaking
lightning imagine that unlimited Evan
Vee
okay so what if we shoot the unlimited
lightning I'm Richard Wow
that's cool man dude we're gonna have so
much fun okay I'm sure there's somewhere
where you can actually use it like here
that would make sense right
yeah Oh watch out for the giant stones
all right trickle let's let's go Treecko
hey ho boo hey it's letting on [ __ ] [ __ ]
this baby Viet man yah ti3
all over Makana disowned eunuch Alberto
wz Oh nanny your Tatas dizzy oh [ __ ] it
doesn't seem man-eating to me oh my god
this is wonderful
look at oh okay nailed that jump tonight
careful now Treecko you're a little
bigger than me I don't know how to say
that in a polite way
oh okay we're gonna have him shoot
lightning again it's time boy
it's like it got a living Tesla coil
with me
it's [ __ ] awesome dude I do not
expect this this is cool all right well
let's keep going easy with me are you
with me Treecko is so cute oh my god
okay what whoa
all right so pretty oh it's so pretty
let's jump in whoa whoa did I just hit
the only piece of wood in the plug-in
water okay so we got stuff over here we
got stuff over here let's swim over here
I bet treecko's like scared of water
what a nerd all right yeah I wanted to
jump in Treecko
look at him but I don't like to take
baths
it looks like Edgar in a bathtub pretty
much all right
yeah he's telling us about
boom bada bing bada boom
Thank You trigger it's been a pleasure
as always
um okay you wait there I'll be right
that back yeah yeah of course
climber's chain that is how you climb
chains everybody it plays a lot smoother
than when I played it I think they fix a
lot of the controls which is cool
maybe I'm saying that too soon I don't
know but it looks like a puzzle here I
like puzzles I can dig it
alright we got a box with filled with
butterfly candy and we can grip by
holding down okay dude you're pushing
now this is not really what I was your
really suck at pushing dude
there we go really nailed it
it's Treecko out there maybe we need to
trick Oh to go in the water yeah these
jokes are gonna get old real fast I know
we're just getting started as well there
it is dude whoo it tickles my balls yes
Let Go button is thanks all right let's
get one a Drake though I got your
favorite candy you want some butterfly
drugs well come gadem oh my god the
water
oh okay let's go get another one another
one another one
hey drink oh I know you like the cane so
I got you one not that one I don't think
he needs more than that I think that was
nobody needs three let's jump on top of
him I'm driving
god damn you smell when you're wet okay
now where do we go oh cool we can go
here it all makes sense thank you
but man I'm praying oh my god
hey hey hey buddy oh god don't fall down
don't for that thank you
dude Treecko oh my God he's is he
shaking off like a wet dog hey how you
doing boots
you're looking real nice thank you for
that butterfly snack I really appreciate
it
hey man no problem hey what's over here
more snacks um I don't know Jesus Christ
give me a sec like I have to do
everything actually that's not true he
can shoot lightning out of its ass
okay all right Treecko I'm gonna be
right back
just whatever just come back with more
snacks please like all so cute oh my god
I wish I'd go was actually cute like
that whoa well well well what do we have
here beautiful absolutely beautiful
[Music]
horrible
oh yeah CUDA you d yeah no see I wrote a
no you can't just leave him what all
right we're gonna pause the first
episode right here we're gonna start off
a little slower and then we're gonna
keep up the pace
so everyone can keep up but this is
really cool I'm really really enjoying
this and I would really hope if you guys
join me on this adventure leave a like
if you enjoyed and I'll see you tomorrow
with a new part and we can go through
this link together I'm really excited I
think it'll be a lot of fun it's been a
while since we did a playthrough on this
channel so I hope you join me on this
and as always stay awesome brush
[Music]